c'est le cauchemar de tous les parents
une fillette de 7 ans frappée par un
véhicule alors qu'elle marchait vers
l'école
justement on a plusieurs appels on a
fait un pour nous rapporter une
collision entre un véhicule et un piéton
à l'angle des rues partenaire et de
Rouen
intervenir ces quatre personnes là faut
le dire ce sont des gens qui sont formés
pour intervenir dans des situations
comme ça peu importe le type de
situation mais même avec une médicale
l'histoire bouleverse
qui sont ébranlés
et aussi choqué notamment parce que le
conducteur ne s'est pas arrêté changer
pas été témoin
tous les jours en vélo dans ce coin de
la ville c'est facile mourir
deux gens là
2 janvier à septembre 39 piétons ont
perdu la vie sur les routes du Québec
une hausse de 14,7% par rapport à la
même période en 2021 à Montréal 18
piétons sont morts en date du 12
décembre cette année ils étaient 11 l'an
passé on assiste un peu à une hécatombe
malheureusement il y a eu plus de 5
décès dans la dernière semaine et
également 5 blessés graves ici le drame
était annoncé selon les résidents de ce
quartier résidentiel du centre-ville un
corridor scolaire enclavé par des
artères à chalandais vendredi passé vers
les 16 heures j'ai failli me faire
frapper la même place la voiture a pas
arrêté personne n'est surpris de cet axe
site et encore plus depuis le début des
travaux du pont tunnel selon plusieurs
citoyens mobilisés comme François
desonniers d'ailleurs vous voyez les
panneaux qui sont qui viennent est
installés il y a quelques semaines
seulement avec interdise le virage à
gauche qui ne soit pas respecté c'est
une mesure et l'administration en mise
en si on veut rapidement suite à nos
commentaires on est en mouvement dans le
centre sud sans quartier aussi qui est
pas évident on a des grosses
infrastructures de transport le défi
entre la gestion de la circulation et la
sécurité des piétons ici Jacques Audric
Charbonneau Radio-Canada Montréal